[Music]
[Applause]
darren revell the action network daryn's
been covering the
athletes and uh their name image and
likeness longer than anybody in the
business we figured he'd be the right
guy to talk
to this is a happy national image and
likeness day
darren uh how would you uh sum up what
has happened so far
well i guess in the first uh since 12
midnight
uh dan it seems like it's been a little
bit of a wild wild west with athletes
just signing deals with sports bars my
favorite was
jordan bohannon of iowa doing an
autograph
signing at a fireworks place uh today
but uh yeah no the it's it's gonna be a
cash grab the problem is you know there
is still some compliance here
the people are going to have to check
with their compliance departments and
make sure they're not
breaking rules there are rules that are
still in place here dan so
uh people who have social media
followings huge social media followings
are expected to cash in
and we're just going to have to see if
this is just fool's gold
or if there's some real money to be made
by a bunch of people
you just tweeted that the uh one of my
favorite college players
derek stingley jr the cornerback at lsu
has signed with a sports bar that has 19
locations within louisiana
like an ambassador for a sports bar yeah
exactly i mean these are like
typical endorsement deals um you know
the
i think where people have not uh taken
into account
uh you know they think about spencer
rattler in oklahoma
they think about sam howell at unc they
think about the quarterbacks the running
backs all the guys who are lined up for
the heisman and say these guys will make
money
i made a list of 20 people uh yesterday
and half of them were women uh
volleyball players
uh alana walker antoine walker's
daughter
the cavender twins the the twins who are
on the fresno state basketball team
uh there's a girl uh named olivia dunn
who's a gymnast
at lsu who's expected to sign more than
a million dollars worth of deals today
she has a ticket bottling of 3.9 million
people
so it's not only just athletes who are
using sport
to get the endorsement it's also people
who happen to be athletes
who've used their stage to become
influencers and now can take money
but you start to look at this and i'm
guessing universities are hiring
compliance officers or people who can
help the athletes business managers
can an athlete hire
an agent can you have an engage an agent
that is helping you with endorsements
yeah athletes can do that um there is a
fine line here obviously
most of them right now are pretty much
operating through direct message on
instagram
uh there are standard booster rules
obviously
a lot of people say oh this is going to
be the way to cheat an
inducement to be recruited uh hey
i'll do an autograph signing after you
sign you'll do
5000 pieces or you'll do one piece for
me
and i'll pay you uh 500 000
the one thing that's so crazy about this
dan is that the
ncaa has not had any rules as far as
what is the price
that should be like if this person has
this many followers
this is the price that it should be in
this range
if not you know it's got to be double or
triple checked
there is no one on the ncaa side or
anyone who the ncaa has hired
who are who are checking these things um
this
it's all up to the schools uh and then
one more thing with the schools
what happens if if derek stingley jr
signs with walk-ons
but the main sponsorship with lsu is
their competitor
i expect that to happen a lot now right
like yo
we can pay less lsu is wanting this
where we want to ambush
the the official sponsor because you
know we're their competitor
i can see that happening what about high
school athletes
it's really once you sign uh
that's the rule um but then the question
is are guys gonna sign
earlier uh for example arch manning
i mean their arch manning
i could see could make 10 million
dollars as a freshman
in college um he's he everyone who had
peyton
and eli are are going to want to sign
him
um there's no one really now coming up
that like
you see he's the guy when you say who's
the guy
who is going to go to college and just
blow this thing up
that's the guy who i think of so but
he's got two years to go
the question is and there's still a lot
of questions here if he commits to a
school
does that start the timeline is there
going to be a salary cap
they're not going to cap anything um
so they're not allowed to the ncaa just
had a
had a case that they that they lost um
where they're they're just going to be
really sensitive to capping
everything i mean the question is going
to be how much
are the schools going to help out the
kids there's one thing that's kind of
the elephant in the room here
is you know when i'm talking about name
image and likeness and i've been
covering this since at least 2000
uh it's always jersey sales i'm a fan
i want the name on the back of the
jersey
but it's just always this weird thing
where they have the number
you know who it is that's why you're
buying it but it doesn't have the guy's
name on the back
jerseys are not in this conversation
because it requires
a business deal between the player and
the school
and they're just that's down the road
you're not
allowed to use any of the schools
trademarks or logos with anything you
sell
derek stingley cannot appear in lsu
jersey in a commercial for walk-ons
um you can i believe have autograph
signings and the texas quarterback
can sign a longhorns helmet but he can't
create anything and you you don't
automatically get the trademarks of the
schools
there is so much to learn here and i
think it's there's a lot of concerns i
think too
you know there the irs has not ruled at
all on this
does this make athletes employees and
all of a sudden is their education
taxable i mean there there are a lot of
questions here that have not been
answered
who do you think is the most marketable
college athlete
in the past that had this been in place
when they were in
in uh college who could have capitalized
tebow yeah that's why i would say it
goes i would say it goes tebow
uh bush manziel those would be my top
three
um but tebow tebow sold so many jerseys
he would be the example i mean he would
have made on a jersey deal
that he would have made a hundred
thousand dollars easy on jerseys he's
the best selling college
jersey of all time who's second
i would probably say
i mean bush probably was was there
although obviously that was like oh
five so it was a different era but but
but i would
i would i would say probably bush would
be number two because basketball jerseys
don't sell
the same amount of football jerseys do
we're talking to darren
tell her you're on tv right now yeah you
can text her
um it's also happy bobby bonilla day
you've been uh covering this story for a
long long time
bobby bonilla the former new york met so
he gets paid what one point
one million dollars one million one
hundred
nineteen thousand two hundred forty
eight dollars and twenty cents
every july first every july first so the
deal was the mets didn't want to pay him
in 2000
he had 5.9 million owed they gave him
eight percent
uh interest a year starting in 2010
to play and pay him for the next 25
years so today
is the 11th installment of that deal
will get paid till
2035. i'm going to guess that was a bad
deal by the mets darin
well if you think about it at the time
they had a financial advisor named
bernie madoff
who was getting them 10 to 15 a year of
course
so in retrospect that that seemed all
right you know the question is we had
fun today
everyone says hey that's the greatest
deal for bobby bonilla if bobby benia
took the and obviously i'm just being a
jerk here
but if bobby took the 5.9 million and he
put it into
amazon stock on the day the deal was
structured
he would have 220 million today now he
he could have also put that into
pets.com which
eight months later uh went bankrupt and
was worth zero but
just to have fun thank you darren you
got it all right
that's darren revell the action network
can now answer the phone call from his
wife